If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click Gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible
如果您想从本节目中获得更多内容，请加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节的临近，您还可以为您生命中热爱历史的人赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”（Gifts）即可。本集由Hive赞助。英国曾以工业力量的强大彻底改变了未来。但现在，您可以利用Hive的力量掌控并改变您自己的能源未来。Hive充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并使您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。而Hive的恒温器使这一切成为可能
for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger. your car charge quietly overnight. Recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together. Heating, charging and solar managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires
让您无需动一根手指，只需动动拇指、挑挑眉毛，就能为家中供暖。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其保持在您想要的精确位置。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive的电动汽车充电器让您的汽车在夜间安静地充电。在您休息的同时完成充电。Hive将这一切融为一体。供暖、充电和太阳能管理，一切尽在一个简单的应用程序中，实现了一场安静的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive最终帮助您了解属于您的能源。前往hivehome.com了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive应用程序兼容特定技术。盈余支付需要
SEG tariff Dear mother I'm writing from the trenches it is 11 o'clock in the morning beside me is a coke fire opposite me a dug out with straw in it the ground is sloppy in the actual trench
SEG关税。亲爱的母亲，我正从战壕里写信，现在是上午11点。我旁边是一个焦炭火炉，对面是一个铺着稻草的防空洞。战壕里的地面很泥泞，
but frozen elsewhere in my mouth is a pipe presented by the princess mary in the pipe is tobacco of course you say but wait in the pipe is german tobacco ha ha you say from a prisoner or found in a captured trench oh dear no from a german soldier yes a live german soldier from his own trench yesterday the british and germans met and shook hands in the ground between the trenches and exchanged souvenirs and shook hands
但在其他地方却结了冰。我嘴里叼着玛丽公主赠送的烟斗，烟斗里当然是烟草，您会说，但等等，烟斗里装的是德国烟草，哈哈，您会说，是从俘虏身上拿的还是在缴获的战壕里找到的？哦，亲爱的，不，是从一名德国士兵那里得到的。是的，一名活着的德国士兵，从他自己的战壕里。昨天，英国人和德国人在战壕之间的空地上见面并握手，交换了纪念品，并握手
yes all day Christmas Day and as I write marvellous isn't it so that was the 19 year old Henry Williamson of the London Rifle Brigade writing to his parents in Southeast London on the 26th of December
是的，整个圣诞节那天。正如我所写的那样，这不是很奇妙吗？这就是伦敦步枪旅19岁的亨利·威廉姆森在12月26日写给他在伦敦东南部父母的信，
1914 about the previous day, Christmas Day, 1914. And Dominic, what could possibly be more festive than this topic? You're right, Tom. So he's describing the Christmas truce. And Henry Williamson, some of our listeners may be familiar with that name because he is the author of a book called Tark the Otter, a nature classic that I think was published about a decade after the First World War and has never been out of print since then. A real kind of perennial children's classic.
讲述的是前一天，即1914年圣诞节的事情。多米尼克，还有什么比这个话题更具节日气氛的呢？你说得对，汤姆。他描述的是圣诞休战。亨利·威廉姆森，我们的一些听众可能对这个名字很熟悉，因为他是《水獭塔克》（Tark the Otter）一书的作者，这是一部自然文学经典，我想它是在第一次世界大战后大约十年出版的，此后从未绝版。这真是一部经久不衰的儿童经典。
Right water was the film, isn't it? That's right, yeah, Ring of Bright Water, exactly. So he's describing there a story that I think most people would rank as one of the most poignant of the 20th century. So it's the informal truce between British and German soldiers in no man's land on Christmas Day, 1914. And I think we always imagine it as this sort of precious oasis, this moment of peace amid the slaughter, hope amid the horror. The very best of humanity, Tom, in the grimmest circumstances in human history. And Dominic, your tone, your tone there. I'm fearful of where you may be heading with this festive episode.
对，那是同名电影，对吧？没错，就是《明亮水域之环》（Ring of Bright Water），确实如此。所以他描述的故事，我认为大多数人会将其列为20世纪最令人感伤的故事之一。这是1914年圣诞节那天，英国和德国士兵在“无人区”进行的非正式休战。我想我们总是把它想象成一种珍贵的绿洲，在屠杀中获得片刻的安宁，在恐怖中看到希望。汤姆，这是人类历史上最严峻的环境下，人性最美好的一面。多米尼克，你的语气，你刚才的语气。我担心你在这个节日特辑里要讲些什么。
Where am I going to take it? I mean, actually, who cares about what I think? Because what people really think when they think about the first world was, what does Paul McCartney think? I tell you what Paul McCartney thinks, he lights a candle to our love. Because in love, our problems disappear. Yeah, of course. And that's from the Pipes of Peace, 1983, which was, I think, a number one in Britain and in Ireland, but not in America, which is sad from the Americans. Well, Paul is playing both a British officer and a German officer on either sides of the trenches, and they get up and they exchange photographs, don't they?
我要把它引向何方？我的意思是，实际上，谁在乎我的想法呢？因为当人们想到第一次世界大战时，他们真正想的是，保罗·麦卡特尼怎么想？我告诉你保罗·麦卡特尼是怎么想的，他为我们的爱点亮了一支蜡烛。因为在爱中，我们的问题消失了。是的，当然。那是1983年的《和平之笛》（Pipes of Peace），我想它在英国和爱尔兰都获得了冠军，但在美国没有，这对美国人来说很遗憾。好吧，保罗在战壕两边分别扮演了一名英国军官和一名德国军官，他们站起来交换了照片，不是吗？
That's right, yeah. And there are some examples. So the Christmas truce often appears in popular culture. So for younger listeners, in Britain, there was a very celebrated ad. an advert for Sainsbury's the supermarket in 2014, which a lot of people may remember. Which was the centenary of it happening. Exactly. And it's one of those ads that kind of went viral and it had the soldiers playing football
没错。而且有一些例子。所以圣诞休战经常出现在流行文化中。对于年轻的听众来说，在英国，2014年有一个非常著名的广告，那是塞恩斯伯里超市（Sainsbury's）的广告，很多人可能还记得。那是事件发生一百周年。没错。这是那种病毒式传播的广告之一，里面有士兵们在踢足球
between the trenches and will come to this issue whether or not they played football. People who like Doctor Who, the very last Peter Capaldi story, was set in no man's land on Christmas Day. That was on 2017. Again, it was the kind of Christmas truce as the backdrop. And I guess it plays a huge part, a central part actually, in what Michael Goulders. Gove when he was education secretary called the kind of black adder version of the First World War. So this is the idea that basically the war was for nothing. It was a tragic waste.
在战壕之间，我们稍后会讨论他们是否真的踢了足球。喜欢《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）的人会知道，彼得·卡帕尔迪的最后一个故事就是以1917年圣诞节的“无人区”为背景的。同样，它也是以圣诞休战为背景的。我想它在迈克尔·戈夫担任教育大臣时所说的“黑爵士”（Blackadder）版本的第一次世界大战中扮演了重要角色，实际上是核心角色。所以这就是那种认为战争毫无意义、纯属悲剧性浪费的观点。
There were these corrupt, cruel old generals sending young men to die when actually the young men just wanted to shake hands, exchange tobacco. Play football. Play football. Exactly. And Tom, it will astound you. I know you're nervous about where I'm going to take this. I'm not nervous at all. I'm full of festive excitement. It would astound you to hear. I have my suspicions as to where you're going with this. That the reality of the Christmas juice was a bit more complicated. Who knew? So we'll be asking today, did it happen?
有那些腐败、残忍的老将军派年轻人去送死，而实际上年轻人只是想握手、交换烟草。踢足球。踢足球。没错。汤姆，这会让你大吃一惊。我知道你很担心我要把话题引向何方。我一点也不担心。我充满了节日的兴奋。听到这个你会大吃一惊的。我怀疑你要讲什么。现实中的圣诞休战要复杂得多。谁知道呢？所以我们今天会问，它真的发生了吗？
Who started it? And why did they start it? What did the ordinary soldiers think about it? Did they really play football between the trenches? And here's the big question. If they could stop on Christmas Day, how is it that they carried on? Why didn't they just shake hands and go home? That is the question that Paul asks in the Pipes of Peace.
谁发起的？他们为什么要发起？普通士兵对此有何看法？他们真的在战壕之间踢足球了吗？这是一个大问题。如果他们能在圣诞节停火，为什么他们还要继续打下去？为什么他们不直接握手回家呢？这就是保罗在《和平之笛》中提出的问题。
Well, Paul, if you're listening, we're going to, answer that question today. Let us set the festive scene. So it's December 1914. The First World War has been going for almost five months, Britain, France and Russia on one side, the Allies or the Entente, and Germany and Austria, Hungary on the other. And people who listened to our series in the summer, that was episodes 594 onwards, will recall that in the sort of late summer in autumn, the Germans launched this huge offensive in the West. They're driven back at the battle of them on, and they end up cutting these trench networks in the chalk, this long defensive line, like a kind of scar through Flanders in Belgium and Eastern France. And they dig deeper and
好吧，保罗，如果你在听的话，我们今天会回答这个问题。让我们设定一下节日场景。现在是1914年12月。第一次世界大战已经进行了近五个月，英国、法国和俄国在一边，即盟军或协约国，德国和奥匈帝国在另一边。夏天听过我们系列节目的听众，也就是第594集以后的内容，会记得在夏末秋初，德国人在西线发动了大规模攻势。他们在马恩河战役中被击退，最终在白垩土中挖掘了这些战壕网络，这是一条漫长的防线，就像在比利时和法国东部的法兰德斯地区留下的一道伤疤。他们挖得越来越
deeper as the rains come, and they basically dig in for the long haul. And there's constant attempts to break the defences, but by the, let's say, the end of November, 1914, the weather has changed, it's pouring with rain, and the fighting sort of, it doesn't dwindle to nothing, but it just dies down a little bit and becomes kind of institutionalised. So that's when you basically get the Western Front. In the winter, there is still a feeling, isn't that this is kind of temporary and that come the summer, you know, it's the fighting season, they'll get out of the trenches and have a traditional Napoleonic-style war. So there isn't yet the sense that this is going to be grinding horror with rats and mud forever and ever. No, there's rats at the moment,
深，随着雨季到来，他们基本上是做好了长期作战的准备。虽然不断有人试图突破防线，但到了1914年11月底，天气变了，大雨倾盆，战斗并没有完全停止，但确实减弱了一些，并变得某种程度上“制度化”了。这就是西线的由来。在冬天，人们仍然觉得这只是暂时的，等到夏天，也就是战斗季节到来时，他们就会走出战壕，进行传统的拿破仑式战争。所以当时还没有那种认为这将是伴随着老鼠和泥泞、永无止境的磨难的恐怖感。不，现在有老鼠，
but people think it will end, it will change, you know, come the spring. That said, by the end of 1914, some people are already, rather like Paul McCartney, calling for peace, the pipes of peace. So there's an open letter by 101 British women's suffrage campaigners addressed to the women of Germany and Austria, saying, you know, why can't we, let's all put pressure on our governments to stop the killing. This is madness. Yeah, like Aristophanes. Right, exactly. And then the Pope gets involved, Pope Benedict the 15th. He publishes a paper in cyclical in November. He says the war is the suicide of civilised Europe. He says, I'd like to mediate a truce.
但人们认为它会结束，它会改变，你知道，等到春天。话虽如此，到1914年底，有些人已经像保罗·麦卡特尼一样呼吁和平，即“和平之笛”。所以有101名英国妇女选举权运动者写了一封公开信，致信德国和奥匈帝国的妇女，说，你知道，为什么我们不能一起向我们的政府施压，停止杀戮。这太疯狂了。是的，就像阿里斯托芬一样。没错，正是这样。然后教皇介入了，教皇本笃十五世。他在11月发表了一份通谕。他说战争是文明欧洲的自杀。他说，我想调解一场休战。
Everybody ignores him. But he wasn't wrong, was he? Yeah, he was quite right. It's very rare that you get me commending the Pope. But I'd take my hat off to him on this occasion. Well, that's, again, the festive spirit. Exactly. So a month later, after he's been ignored, he basically appeals to both sides,
每个人都无视他。但他没说错，不是吗？是的，他说得很对。我称赞教皇的情况非常罕见。但在这种情况下，我向他脱帽致敬。好吧，这又是节日精神。没错。所以一个月后，在他被无视之后，他基本上向双方呼吁，
says, please stop fighting over Christmas. And I quote, so that the guns may fall silent, at least upon the night the angels sang. Very nice. And everybody, again, completely ignores him. So people listen to this may think, well, why did these appeals fail? Because both sides had already lost a lot of men. So why did they want to carry on fighting? And the short answer, we talked about this at the end of our First World War series,
说，请在圣诞节期间停止战斗，我引用一下，这样枪声至少可以在天使歌唱的夜晚归于沉寂。非常好。而每个人再次完全无视他。所以听众可能会想，为什么这些呼吁失败了？因为双方都已经损失了很多人。那么他们为什么还要继续战斗呢？简短的回答，我们在第一次世界大战系列节目的最后讨论过，
is that they actually want to keep fighting. They want to achieve their war aims. So the Allies, the British and French, for example, they want to drive the Germans out. The Germans are still in Belgium. They're occupying a 10th of France. So the Allies aren't going to stop. And the Germans themselves aren't going to stop.
是他们实际上想继续战斗。他们想实现他们的战争目标。所以盟军，比如英国和法国，他们想把德国人赶出去。德国人仍然在比利时。他们占领了法国十分之一的领土。所以盟军不会停止。而德国人自己也不会停止。
Because they think of the war as this desperate struggle for survival. They think they're encircled. They think that if they lose, it will be a total and utter national disaster. I mean, to be honest, they're not wrong because they do lose and it is. I mean, you just have to look at Ukraine, don't you? Where there's quite a similar kind of deadlock, there are even trenches. Yeah. I think there was a kind of a Christmas truce.
因为他们认为这场战争是一场绝望的生存斗争。他们认为自己被包围了。他们认为如果他们输了，那将是一场彻底的民族灾难。说实话，他们没想错，因为他们确实输了，而且确实如此。我的意思是，你只需要看看乌克兰，不是吗？那里也有类似的僵局，甚至还有战壕。是的。我想当时确实有一种圣诞休战。
But obviously it didn't last because neither side is going to just walk away. Yeah, they believe in their cause and they want to achieve their goals. And actually the fact they've lost so many men makes, you know, actually emboldens them, makes them their resistance more dogged. So the British expeditionary force has been almost completely destroyed by this point and replaced by new men. The Germans and the French have lost about half a million men each. But they don't want to stop because they think if they did that, it would dishonour the
但显然它没有持续下去，因为双方都不会就这样走开。是的，他们相信自己的事业，想要实现自己的目标。事实上，他们损失了这么多人，反而使他们更加大胆，使他们的抵抗更加顽强。所以英国远征军到这个时候几乎被完全摧毁，并被新兵取代。德国和法国各损失了大约五十万人。但他们不想停止，因为他们认为如果那样做，就会玷污那些
sacrifice of those men who have fallen. So that's the context. Let's get into the trenches in December 1914. And specifically, we're going to be looking at the 20 miles. stretch of the Western Front, which is held by the British on one side and the Germans and the other south of Ypres in Belgium. So the men in these lines are newcomers by and large. They are reservists, their new recruits who have been rushed in to take the place of the forces that were originally destroyed in the first few months of the war. And that's true of the Germans as
牺牲者的荣誉。这就是背景。让我们进入1914年12月的战壕。具体来说，我们将看看西线20英里的地带，这一地带由英国人把守一边，德国人把守另一边，位于比利时伊普尔以南。所以这些战线上的士兵大多是新人。他们是预备役军人，是匆忙赶来填补战争最初几个月被摧毁的部队空缺的新兵。德国人也是如此，
well. So they have poured in kind of young, inexperienced men, often from Saxony and Bavaria, from Prussia. The British always said, the Prussians are the worst. They're kind of dour and dogged and formidable. Bullet-headed. Yeah. Whereas the Saxons and the Bavarians were jollier. Yes. So you get the first reports of fraternisation
他们也投入了年轻、缺乏经验的人，通常来自萨克森、巴伐利亚和普鲁士。英国人总是说，普鲁士人是最糟糕的。他们那种阴沉、顽固且令人生畏。子弹头脑袋。是的。而萨克森人和巴伐利亚人则更快乐。是的。所以你得到了关于战壕之间
between the trenches. This is so interesting. It may surprise some listeners. The fraternisation actually begins well before Christmas. So it actually happens from early November or so, from the point at which they dig in. And what would happen is, there would be a sort of informal shouted arrangement or possibly, you know, sort of agreed by two men in meeting in no man's land or something,
联欢的最初报道。这太有趣了。这可能会让一些听众感到惊讶。联欢实际上在圣诞节前很久就开始了。它实际上从11月初左右就开始了，从他们挖掘战壕的时候开始。会发生的情况是，会有一种非正式的喊话安排，或者可能（你知道）由两个人在无人区见面达成某种协议，
you know, we'll have a pause at this particular point in the day so that we can both wash or we can have our evening meals or because there's loads of bodies piled up in no man's land and we'd like to retrieve our mates and bury the dead, or because the weather is really terrible, you know, it's pouring and pouring with rain, the trenches on both sides are flooded and basically someone shouts out, you know, should we have a break so that both of us can repair our trenches, which might strike people as mad, but I mean, you know. Well, but maybe it doesn't if you are not a professional soldier and, you know, you've working in a shop or an office or something and suddenly you find yourself in the winter,
你知道，我们在一天中的某个特定时间暂停，这样我们都可以洗漱，或者我们可以吃晚饭，或者因为无人区堆满了尸体，我们想找回我们的伙伴并埋葬死者，或者因为天气真的很糟糕，你知道，大雨倾盆，双方的战壕都被淹了，基本上有人喊道，你知道，我们能不能休息一下，以便我们双方都能修理战壕，这在人们看来可能很疯狂，但我的意思是，你知道。好吧，但如果你不是职业军人，而且你以前在商店或办公室工作，突然发现自己身处冬天，
in mud, facing people, you know really nothing about. Wouldn't that make it likelier that you might kind of try and reach out and have an accommodation because you're not a professional soldier? Yeah, of course. Well, I mean, by this point, you are a professional soldier, but you know what I mean. You haven't been raised to it. You haven't been trained to it over many years to fight. Of course.
在泥泞中，面对着你一无所知的人，也许这就不那么疯狂了。难道这不会让你更有可能尝试去接触并达成某种妥协吗？因为你不是职业军人？是的，当然。好吧，我的意思是，到这个时候，你已经是职业军人了，但你明白我的意思。你不是从小就接受这种训练。你没有经过多年的训练去战斗。当然。
I mean, it's worth stressing there is always fraternization in wars. You know, this is not unheard of, right? There have been lots of examples in wars before this. Remember that in this case, the front lines are very close together. I mean, you can shout from one line and the other line will hear you. And the fraternization generally starts with the Germans. They're shouting in English. And the reason it works that way is because,
我的意思是，值得强调的是，战争中总是有联欢。你知道，这并非闻所未闻，对吧？在此之前的战争中有很多这样的例子。记住，在这种情况下，前线非常接近。我的意思是，你可以从一条战线喊话，另一条战线就能听到。联欢通常由德国人发起。他们用英语喊话。之所以这样运作，是因为
there had been a real trend before the First World War for young German men, almost like kind of Australians or something today, to come and work in London for a little while to improve their English. They work as waiters. It's a kind of stereotype before the war, the German waiter in a London restaurant. Yeah, so just to focus in on another angle then about what might have fostered fraternisation, is there a sense even now that there is still a degree of commonality between Britain and Germany? because certainly that's there before the war breaks out, isn't it? And I guess this is likely to happen between British and Germans and say French and Germans. Yeah. So the reason it wouldn't happen between French and Germans is, of course, the war is being fought on French soil. French losses have been much heavier.
在第一次世界大战之前，有一种真正的趋势，年轻的德国人，就像今天的澳大利亚人或其他什么人一样，会来伦敦工作一段时间以提高英语水平。他们做服务员。这是战前的一种刻板印象，伦敦餐馆里的德国服务员。是的，那么让我们关注另一个关于什么可能促进了联欢的角度，是否有一种感觉，即使是现在，英国和德国之间仍然存在某种程度的共同点？因为在战争爆发前，这种共同点肯定存在，不是吗？而且我猜这更有可能发生在英国人和德国人之间，而不是法国人和德国人之间。是的。所以它不会发生在法国人和德国人之间，原因当然是战争是在法国领土上进行的。法国的损失要重得多。
And for the French, this is existential, right? This is their homeland from which they're trying to drive the invader. The British are fighting on what they regard as, you know, it's a sort of neutral venue. It's in a way match for them as it is for the Germans. And I think, you know, we talked about this in previous series. Before the First World War, there was so much stuff about the kind of, the fraternal links between England and Germany, you know, the Anglo-Saxon heritage, all of that. And of course, that ends up being erased by wartime propaganda. But we're only a few months into the war.
对于法国人来说，这是生存问题，对吧？这是他们试图将入侵者赶出去的家园。英国人是在他们认为是“中立场地”的地方作战。这对他们来说和对德国人来说一样，在某种程度上是一场比赛。而且我认为，正如我们在之前的系列节目中讨论的那样，在第一次世界大战之前，有很多关于英国和德国之间兄弟联系的内容，你知道，盎格鲁-撒克逊遗产等等。当然，这些最终都被战时宣传抹去了。但我们离战争开始才几个月。
So I think there's still a lot of sort of, well, not a lot, but there are still a slight element of fellow feeling. And I mean, a very obvious symbol of that cultural influence. of Germany on Britain is the Christmas tree, right? Which had been brought over by various roles, but particularly by Prince Albert, Queen Victoria's husband. And so, you know, that is a very vivid symbol of this shared culture. I mean, football will come to football. The Germans have basically imported football from Britain. And some of these people who've been waiters in London are shouting out about football. They're saying, who's top of the first division? How are, you know, Tottenham Hotsburgh getting on or whatever? Although, at this point,
所以我认为仍然存在一种，嗯，不能说很多，但仍然存在一种轻微的同情心。我的意思是，德国对英国文化影响的一个非常明显的象征就是圣诞树，对吧？它是由各种角色带来的，特别是维多利亚女王的丈夫阿尔伯特亲王。所以，你知道，这是这种共享文化的一个非常生动的象征。我的意思是，足球，我们来谈谈足球。德国人基本上是从英国引进了足球。而其中一些曾在伦敦当过服务员的人正在大声谈论足球。他们会问，谁是甲级联赛的第一名？托特纳姆热刺队表现如何等等？虽然在这一点上，
point, football isn't the kind of obsession that it will become for Germans. It's much bigger in Britain, isn't it, than in Germany? Yeah, agreed. So there were sort of reports of informal fraternisation. And actually, as Christmas approaches, some of the senior commanders are worried that this might get out of hand. So we talked before about a guy called General Horace Smith Dorian, and he was this sort of very gallant kind of swashbuckling British commander who actually before the war had shocked people at the public school officer training corps by saying there should never be a war in Europe. It will destroy civilization. You know, and everyone had thought, gosh, this guy's an absolute, you know, look at this, this pinko pacifist kind of
这一点上，足球还不是后来德国人那种痴迷的程度。它在英国比在德国要大得多，不是吗？是的，同意。所以有一些关于非正式联谊的报道。实际上，随着圣诞节的临近，一些高级指挥官担心这可能会失控。所以我们之前谈到了一个叫霍勒斯·史密斯-多里安将军的人，他是一个非常勇敢、那种敢作敢为的英国指挥官，实际上在战争之前，他曾在公立学校军官训练团震惊了人们，他说欧洲永远不应该发生战争。它会摧毁文明。你知道，每个人都认为，天哪，这家伙绝对是个，你看，这是一种粉红色的和平主义者，
telling us that he doesn't agree with war and whatnot. Anyway, he's now ended up in command. And he issues an order on the 5th of December. And he says, if, you know, it's very common, he says, when you're close to the enemy for men to slide into, a live and let live theory of life. They can become too pally. They lose sight of what he calls the sole object of war and sink into a military lethargy from which it's difficult to arouse them. And so as a result, he says, however tempting and occasionally amusing they may be, friendly intercourse with the enemy, unofficial armistices and the exchange of tobacco and other comforts are absolutely prohibited. However, I think those key.
告诉我们他不同意战争之类的。总之，他现在最终担任了指挥官。他在12月5日发布了一项命令。他说，如果，你知道，这很常见，他说，当你靠近敌人时，人们很容易陷入一种“活着并让别人活着”的生活理论。他们可能会变得太亲密。他们会忘记他所说的战争的唯一目标，并陷入一种难以唤醒的军事冷漠中。因此，他说，无论它们多么诱人，偶尔多么有趣，与敌人进行友好的交往、非正式的停战以及交换烟草和其他慰问品都是绝对禁止的。然而，我认为那些关键的。
words there are, however tempting and occasionally amusing they may be, because it shows that even the man at the top can see the appeal. That actually sometimes, it's a moment of tremendous relief in escapism to shake hands with the opponent. Anyway, we approach Christmas Day. The weather has been dreadful, pouring with rain, and so the recent fighting has been very desultry. And on both sides, British and German, people are thinking a lot about Christmas. So in the British newspapers, there have been all these appeals for the public to send tobacco. and sweets and chocolates and Christmas puddings even. I don't know how they'd cook them,
词是，无论它们多么诱人，偶尔多么有趣，因为它表明即使是最高层的人也能看到其中的吸引力。实际上，有时与对手握手是一种巨大的解脱和逃避现实的时刻。总之，我们临近圣诞节。天气一直很糟糕，大雨倾盆，所以最近的战斗非常零星。双方，英国和德国，人们都在思考圣诞节。所以英国报纸上到处都是呼吁公众寄送烟草、糖果、巧克力甚至圣诞布丁的呼吁。我不知道他们怎么煮，
but anyway, Christmas puddings, plum puddings to the front. The Royal Family have organised the sending of 350,000 Princess Mary gift tin. So Henry Williamson, in that quotation, mentioned his Princess Mary stuff. So you'd basically get a tin, and it had Princess Mary's face on it, and inside there was some chocolate and tobacco and cigarettes and stuff,
但总之，把圣诞布丁、李子布丁送到前线。皇室组织寄送了35万个玛丽公主礼品罐。所以亨利·威廉姆森在那个引语中提到了他的玛丽公主的东西。所以你基本上会得到一个罐子，上面有玛丽公主的脸，里面有一些巧克力、烟草和香烟之类的东西，
and you got a lovely Christmas message from George V. And that's great. And it's also great because in a hundred years' time, it will enable Sainsbury's to use that as a way of flogging their own groceries, won't it? Exactly. Exactly. So everyone's a winner. Because it's a huge thing with chocolate or some sort of and tins in the Sainsbury's adverts. Now that said, although they've got this inspiring message from George V, one of Britain's very finest kings, most of the men are pretty miserable because they've been sitting there in this rain.
你还收到了乔治五世的一条可爱的圣诞信息。这太棒了。而且这也很棒，因为一百年后，它将使塞恩斯伯里超市能够利用这一点来推销他们自己的杂货，不是吗？正是如此。正是如此。所以每个人都是赢家。因为在塞恩斯伯里的广告中，巧克力或某种罐头是一个巨大的卖点。话虽如此，尽管他们收到了乔治五世（英国最优秀的国王之一）的鼓舞人心的信息，但大多数人还是非常痛苦，因为他们一直坐在雨中。
They're cold, they're muddy, all of this. But the magic of Christmas. When they wake on Christmas Eve, something has changed. So the rain has stopped. There's been a hard frost overnight, and the ground is kind of dusted with ice and snow. So rather like you see in the adverts and the Pormacana's video and stuff. Christmas Eve is as normal. There's this sort of slightly desultry fighting and firing on both sides, gunfire.
他们又冷又泥泞，所有这些。但圣诞节的魔力。当他们在平安夜醒来时，事情发生了变化。雨停了。一夜之间结了严霜，地面上覆盖着冰雪。所以就像你在广告和波尔卡纳的视频中看到的那样。平安夜和往常一样。双方都有点零星的战斗和开火，枪声。
But late that afternoon, the firing starts to die down as normal. And then the Germans do something unexpected. So we mentioned the presents that the British have had from home, and the Germans have had presents too. The Kaiser, our old friend the Kaiser, has sent them cigarettes and tobacco. But he and his men have also sent them lots of little Christmas trees, hundreds of little Christmas trees all across the front. And as night falls, the Germans start putting up these Christmas trees
但那天下午晚些时候，枪声像往常一样开始减弱。然后德国人做了一些意想不到的事情。所以我们提到了英国人从家里收到的礼物，德国人也收到了礼物。德皇，我们的老朋友德皇，给他们寄了香烟和烟草。但他和他的手下也给他们寄了很多小圣诞树，整个前线有数百棵小圣诞树。随着夜幕降临，德国人开始把这些圣诞树放在
on the kind of parapets of their trenches, and they light candles. Go on, Tom. I can see you're giving up to say something sardonic about the German candle lighting. No, not at all. I just wanted to mention at this point a podcast by a mutual friend of ours, Jonathan Wilson, with Rob Draper. It Was What It Was. Great title. Yeah, it's maybe not the best. But his podcast about the history of football. And in that, they mention a top fact, which is that these Christmas trees that get sent out to all the various regiments and places, they also send them to U-boats. And they had a very entertaining debate about how exactly you would balance a Christmas tree on a U-boat. How would you balance a Christmas show on a U-boat? Maybe you've lit it with candles and the risk of burning to death in a U-boat, which would be not festive at all. Anyway, I just mentioned that in passing. And also, I just wanted to say about Christmas trees and Christmas Eve for Germans.
他们的战壕胸墙上，并点燃了蜡烛。继续，汤姆。我看得出你正要对德国人的点蜡烛说些讽刺的话。不，一点也不。我只是想在这一点上提一下我们共同的朋友乔纳森·威尔逊和罗伯·德雷珀的播客。《它就是它》。很棒的标题。是的，也许不是最好的。但他的关于足球历史的播客。在其中，他们提到了一个顶级事实，那就是这些寄给各个团和地方的圣诞树，他们也寄给了U型潜艇。他们进行了一场非常有趣的辩论，讨论你到底该如何在U型潜艇上平衡一棵圣诞树。你如何在U型潜艇上平衡圣诞树？也许你用蜡烛点亮了它，而在U型潜艇上被烧死的风险，那一点也不节日。总之，我只是顺便提一下。而且，我还想说一下德国人的圣诞树和平安夜。
The Germans have, like most people on the continent, have a weird attitude to Christmas. Namely, they don't actually celebrate it on Christmas, do they? The main focus is Christmas Eve, which always seems to me mad. It is mad. I don't agree with that. I mean, it's wrong. But presumably the British are not really aware of this. And so they would be, they'd be startled by the sudden appearance of Christmas trees.
德国人，像大陆上的大多数人一样，对圣诞节有一种奇怪的态度。即，他们实际上不在圣诞节那天庆祝，对吧？主要的焦点是平安夜，这对我来说总是显得很疯狂。这确实很疯狂。我不同意这一点。我的意思是，这是不对的。但大概英国人并不真正了解这一点。所以他们会，他们会对圣诞树的突然出现感到惊讶。
They are startled. So that evening, at about 8.30, you get the first reports of Carol singing. Again, this is part of the kind of cliche of the Christmas truce, but it's absolutely true. So at 8.30, a Royal Irish Rifles officer reports to headquarters. Germans have illuminated their trenches, are singing songs and are wishing us a happy Christmas. Compliments are being exchanged, but are nevertheless taking all military precautions. So you get more reports flooding in that the Germans are singing
他们确实感到惊讶。所以那天晚上，大约8点30分，你得到了第一份关于唱颂歌的报告。同样，这是圣诞停战陈词滥调的一部分，但它是绝对真实的。所以8点30分，一名皇家爱尔兰步枪团军官向总部报告。德国人照亮了他们的战壕，正在唱着歌，并祝我们圣诞快乐。双方正在交换问候，但仍然采取了一切军事预防措施。所以你得到更多报告涌入，说德国人正在唱
Stillenacht silent night and the British are replying with the first Noel. I think it's actually quite revealing that these are such mournful carols, aren't they? They're kind of like almost slow kind of laments. Very moving, but you're not going to be singing heart the herald angels sing. You're not going to be belting that out
《平安夜》，而英国人则以《第一支圣诞歌》回应。我认为这些是如此忧郁的颂歌，这实际上很能说明问题，不是吗？它们几乎就像缓慢的哀歌。非常感人，但你不会去唱《听，天使报喜》。你不会大声唱出那个
in the middle of the First World War. And there's some excellent books about the Christmas trees which I'll mention a little bit later, but just for the time being, there are loads of accounts of people lighting candles and singing carols, loads of quotations on an online article by the historian Simon Jones. If you Google the Christmas truce, you'll see it. And there's no doubt whatsoever that it's the Germans who take the lead and they start
在第一次世界大战期间。有一些关于圣诞树的优秀书籍，我稍后会提到，但目前，有很多关于人们点燃蜡烛和唱颂歌的记录，历史学家西蒙·琼斯的一篇在线文章中有很多引语。如果你谷歌搜索“圣诞停战”，你会看到的。毫无疑问，是德国人带头，他们开始
encouraging the British to come out of their trenches. I'll just give one quotation. It's a British soldier called Private Frederick Heath. He wrote a letter home a few days later. And he said, all down our line of trenches, there came to our ears a greeting unique in war. English soldier. A Merry Christmas. A Merry Christmas. They spoke just like that, the Germans. For some little time, we were cautious and did not even answer. Officers fearing treachery ordered the men to be silent. But up and down our line, one heard the men answering that Christmas greeting from the enemy. How could we resist wishing each other a Merry Christmas, even though we might be at each other's throats immediately afterwards? And so they spend the night singing to each other across. no man's land, as he puts it, a night made easier by songs from the German trenches, the pipings of picolos, and from our broad lines, laughter and Christmas carols.
鼓励英国人走出战壕。我只引用一句。那是一位名叫弗雷德里克·希思二等兵的英国士兵。几天后他写了一封家书。他说，沿着我们的战壕线，传来了战争中独特的问候。英国士兵。圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐。他们就是那样说的，德国人。有一段时间，我们很谨慎，甚至没有回答。军官们担心背叛，命令士兵保持沉默。但沿着我们的战壕线，人们听到士兵们回应来自敌人的圣诞问候。我们怎么能拒绝祝对方圣诞快乐呢，即使我们可能在之后立即掐住对方的喉咙？所以他们整晚都在“无人区”对面唱歌，正如他所说，德国战壕里的歌声、短笛的吹奏，以及我们宽阔战线上的笑声和圣诞颂歌，让这个夜晚变得轻松。
Thought strikes me, which is that we discussed in the series we did earlier this year about the atrocities in Belgium and the sense that the Germans have put themselves beyond the pale, you know, the evil Han and all of that. You didn't get that conclusion from me, Tom. No, I know. I know. But there is a sense on the home front, isn't there? That the Germans are just monstrous. Yeah. But clearly there's not a sense of that at all here. They're not thinking this might be a trap. No, I suppose not. But is that not because they have been there for weeks? They know that the Germans men just like them. And as they will, of course, will discover even more the next day. But that's what's interesting, isn't it? Because I would guess that the effect of propaganda in Britain and indeed in Germany is to make them think, well, are they men like us? Are they not monsters out to destroy everyone?
一个想法浮现在我脑海中，那就是我们在今年早些时候做的关于比利时暴行的系列节目中讨论过，德国人把自己置于文明之外，你知道，邪恶的汉人等等。你没有从我这里得到那个结论，汤姆。不，我知道。我知道。但在国内前线有一种感觉，不是吗？德国人简直是怪物。是的。但显然这里根本没有那种感觉。他们不认为这可能是一个陷阱。不，我想不是。但那不是因为他们已经在那里待了几个星期了吗？他们知道德国人就像他们一样。正如他们第二天当然会发现的那样。但这很有趣，不是吗？因为我猜英国乃至德国的宣传效果是让他们认为，嗯，他们是像我们一样的人吗？他们不是要摧毁所有人的怪物吗？
It seems clear that that hasn't entirely taken root, that propaganda war. As we will see later in this episode, there are more truces after this, but they dwindle and they disappear by 1916 and 17. And I think the truth is that over time people became brutalized. But at this point, they're not fully brutalized. So they still see their opponents as human beings like themselves and not as, you know, not simply as the enemy to kill or be killed by. I suppose also there is a lot of sport-based propaganda, isn't there?
看来那种宣传战并没有完全扎根。正如我们稍后将在本集中看到的，此后还有更多的停战，但它们在1916年和1917年逐渐减少并消失了。我认为事实是，随着时间的推移，人们变得残暴了。但在这一点上，他们还没有完全变得残暴。所以他们仍然把对手看作和自己一样的人，而不是，你知道，不仅仅是杀人或被杀的敌人。我想还有很多基于体育的宣传，不是吗？
Certainly in Britain. I don't know whether it's the same in Germany. So, you know, you mentioned this is kind of the equivalent of half-time. Perhaps that's also the sense that, you know, you fight hard, but shake hands. Exactly. So that's Christmas Eve. What about Christmas Day? Christmas Day, dawns, cold and foggy, but by mid-morning, the fog has cleared,
当然在英国。我不知道德国是否也是这样。所以，你知道，你提到这相当于中场休息。也许这也是一种感觉，你知道，你努力战斗，但握手言和。正是如此。这就是平安夜。那圣诞节呢？圣诞节黎明，寒冷多雾，但到上午中期，雾气散去，
and it turns out to be a lovely kind of crisp winter's day. It's not raining, crucially. For a lot of people, the most striking thing is how quiet it is. The guns have been roaring all this time. But on both sides, a lot of officers say, well, we won't fire on Christmas Day, so they just stop. And once one side stops, the other generally then stops as well. And then tentatively at first, you know, they've been making a lot of arrangements over the night. Oh, we'll get out of the trench if you do tomorrow morning.
结果是一个可爱、清爽的冬日。关键是没有下雨。对很多人来说，最引人注目的是它是多么安静。枪炮声一直响个不停。但在双方，很多军官说，好吧，我们圣诞节那天不开火，所以他们就停下来了。一旦一方停下来，另一方通常也会停下来。然后起初是试探性的，你知道，他们整晚都在做很多安排。哦，如果你明天早上出来，我们也会走出战壕。
And men start to do it. And when no one shoots them, other men start doing it. And bit by bit, along probably about two-thirds of this stretch, so we're talking about over a kind of... 12-15-mile stretch, people get out of the trenches and they venture into no man's land on both sides. And when they get there, what do they do? Well, first of all, they have made arrangements often, I'll give you a tin if you give me, you know, some tobacco or whatever. So they exchange their buttons, they exchange souvenirs. Actually, Henry Williamson used the word souvenirs, I think, didn't he?
人们开始这样做。当没有人向他们开枪时，其他人也开始这样做。一点一点地，沿着这段大约三分之二的战线，所以我们谈论的是超过12到15英里的战线，人们走出战壕，冒险进入双方的无人区。当他们到达那里时，他们做了什么？好吧，首先，他们经常做出安排，我给你一个罐头，如果你给我，你知道，一些烟草之类的。所以他们交换纽扣，交换纪念品。实际上，亨利·威廉姆森用了“纪念品”这个词，我想，不是吗？
They exchange buttons and badges. Sometimes they exchange their caps. That seems reckless because you might be shot by your own side. Yeah, I mean, explaining to the Sergeant Major of that in the morning. Why you're dressed as a German. The Germans hand over cigars. The British will give them jam or tit. But, you know, they'll basically sort of, there's a sort of barter system.
他们交换纽扣和徽章。有时他们交换帽子。这看起来很鲁莽，因为你可能会被自己人射杀。是的，我的意思是，向那天早上的军士长解释为什么你打扮得像个德国人。德国人交出雪茄。英国人会给他们果酱或糖果。但是，你知道，他们基本上会，有一种以物易物的系统。
Or a bar of St. Breeze chocolate. Exactly. Sometimes they have lunch together. There's a lovely account of the sixth Cheshers who managed to catch a pig and they roasted it in no man's land and shared it with the Germans. How did they get a pig from? God knows. There was a guy called Bruce Bairn's father who's often quoted in accounts of the Christmas trees because he became a very popular newspaper cartoonist between the wars. He says, I spotted a German officer, some sort of lieutenants, I should think.
或者一块塞恩斯伯里的巧克力。正是如此。有时他们一起吃午饭。有一个关于第六柴郡团的可爱记录，他们设法抓到了一头猪，他们在无人区烤了它，并与德国人分享。他们从哪里弄来的猪？天知道。有一个叫布鲁斯·贝尔恩斯法瑟的人，他在关于圣诞树的记录中经常被引用，因为他在两次世界大战之间成为了一位非常受欢迎的报纸漫画家。他说，我发现了一名德国军官，我想大概是某种中尉。
And being a bit of a collector, I intimated to him that I'd taken a fancy to some of his buttons. I brought out my wire clippers and with a few deft snips removed a couple of his buttons and put them in my pocket. I then gave him two of mine in exchange. And then Ben's father says of the of the truce,
作为一个收藏家，我向他暗示我喜欢他的一些纽扣。我拿出我的剪线钳，用几下灵巧的剪切，取下了他的几个纽扣，放进了我的口袋。然后我给了他两个作为交换。然后贝尔恩斯法瑟谈到停战时说，
the last sight he had a bit was one of his machine gunners who was a bit of an amateur hairdresser in civil life, cutting the unnaturally long hair of the docile Bosch, who was patiently kneeling on the ground while the automatic clippers
他看到的最后一幕是他的一名机枪手，在平民生活中是一个业余理发师，正在剪那个温顺的德国佬那异常长的头发，那个人正耐心地跪在地上，而自动理发剪
crept up the back of his neck. My sense of Germans in the First World War is not that they had mullets. That's an unexpected discovery. Yeah, but he's been in the trenches all this time. The mad thing is, this bloke's got a load of clippers. Now, some activities are a bit more mundane. So actually, they're both sides, spend a lot of the truth fixing up their trenches.
爬上了他的后颈。我对第一次世界大战中德国人的印象并不是他们留着鲻鱼头。这是一个意想不到的发现。是的，但他一直待在战壕里。疯狂的是，这家伙有一堆理发剪。现在，有些活动比较平凡。所以实际上，双方在停战期间花了很多时间修理他们的战壕。
And they're even shared tools with each other to work on their trenches, which is very sweet. Some activities are not so sweet and a bit more sinister. So Simon Jones already mentioned, he quotes a British officer who had a cigar with a shared a cigar with the German sniper. And this sniper very foolishly said, you know, I'm the best shot in the German army. I've killed more men than, you know,
他们甚至互相分享工具来修理战壕，这非常贴心。有些活动没那么贴心，甚至有点阴险。所以西蒙·琼斯已经提到了，他引用了一位英国军官的话，他和一个德国狙击手分享了一支雪茄。这个狙击手非常愚蠢地说，你知道，我是德国军队中最好的射手。我杀的人比，你知道，
most of my comrades put together. And this British officer said, okay. Right. And he noted down this bloke's position so that he could shoot him himself the next day. That's harsh.
我大多数战友加起来还要多。这位英国军官说，好的。明白了。他记下了这家伙的位置，以便第二天能亲自射杀他。这太残酷了。
But actually, the most common thing they did was to bury the dead. There are loads of accounts. Actually, you get one from Henry Williamson, of these mass burials. And so they'll bury them all together. the German officers and men will line up on one side of the grave, the British on the other,
但实际上，他们做的最常见的事情是埋葬死者。有很多记录。实际上，你从亨利·威廉姆森那里得到了一份关于这些集体埋葬的记录。所以他们会把他们一起埋葬。德国军官和士兵会在坟墓的一侧排成一列，英国人在另一侧，
they sing psalms, they read prayers in both languages and whatnot. I mean, none of this sounds that exciting, frankly. There's an awful lot of just sort of loitering and hanging around with your hands in your pockets. But it's clear from people's accounts that men on both sides found this a really remarkable and memorable day. You know, all these letters, the most extraordinary Christmas Day imaginable. I wouldn't have missed that unique and weird Christmas Day for anything. This one from Captain Sir Edward Hulse. He describes singing old Langsine,
他们唱赞美诗，用两种语言朗读祈祷文等等。我的意思是，坦率地说，这一切听起来并不那么令人兴奋。有大量的时间只是闲逛，双手插在口袋里。但从人们的记录中可以清楚地看出，双方的人都觉得这是真正非凡且难忘的一天。你知道，所有这些信件，想象中最非凡的圣诞节。我绝不会错过那个独特而奇怪的圣诞节。这是爱德华·赫尔斯上尉写的。他描述了唱《友谊地久天长》，
with which we all, English, Scots, Irish, Prussians, Vertembergers joined in. It was absolutely astounding. And if I had seen it on a cinematograph film, I should have sworn that it was faked. But one question as we head into the break. Do they talk about the war? I mean, that's the thing that would puzzle. You would think they would, right?
我们所有人都加入了，英国人、苏格兰人、爱尔兰人、普鲁士人、符腾堡人。这绝对令人震惊。如果我在电影胶片上看到它，我会发誓它是伪造的。但在我们进入休息时间之前，有一个问题。他们谈论战争吗？我的意思是，那是令人困惑的事情。你会认为他们会，对吧？
that they talk about what they're doing. Well, unless they want a holiday in every sense from the war. Yeah, a little bit. I think they do talk about it a bit, but as you say, it's boring to a lot of them. They don't really want, they're not going to start discussing the Archduke, Franz Ferdinand. They want to talk about Gavin and Stacey. Yeah, they want to talk about football or something, or about how cold they are, about the quality of their food or whatever.
他们谈论自己正在做的事情。嗯，除非他们想从战争中彻底解脱出来，过个假。是的，有一点。我想他们确实谈论过，但正如你所说，对他们中的许多人来说这很无聊。他们并不真的想，他们不会开始讨论弗朗茨·斐迪南大公。他们想谈论的是《加文和斯泰西》。是的，他们想谈论足球之类的，或者谈论他们有多冷，谈论食物的质量等等。
And actually, the most striking encounter to them talking about the war for me is this guy. we began with Henry Williamson, 19 years old. He watches the burials, and he is struck by the fact that on the German crosses, they write the words, "'Fuevaterland and Freight for Fatherland and Freedom.'" And he's really stunned by this, and I quote, "'Freedom, how was this? We were fighting for freedom.
事实上，对我来说，关于他们谈论战争最引人注目的遭遇是这个人。我们从19岁的亨利·威廉姆森开始。他看着葬礼，他被一个事实所震撼：在德国人的十字架上，他们写着“为了祖国和自由”。他对此感到非常震惊，我引用一下：“自由，这是怎么回事？我们是在为自由而战。”
Our cause was just. We were defending Belgium's civilization. And he says to a German bloke standing next to me speaks English, what's all this? What are you? You're the baddies. What are you thinking? And the German says to him, well, of course we're fighting for freedom. Our cause is just. We are ringed with enemies. So war was thrust on us. We are defending our parents, our homes, a German soil. And Williamson has what he calls a most shaking, staggering thought that both sides thought they were fighting for the same cause. These fellows in grey were good families. They were strangely just men like ourselves. Very philosophical. And also, Dominic, I'm amazed that this hasn't turned out to be a myth. I was fully expecting you to debunk it.
我们的事业是正义的。我们是在捍卫比利时的文明。他对站在旁边的一个会说英语的德国人说，这是怎么回事？你们是什么人？你们是坏人。你们在想什么？那个德国人对他说，嗯，我们当然是在为自由而战。我们的事业是正义的。我们被敌人包围了。所以战争强加给了我们。我们是在保卫我们的父母、我们的家园、德国的土地。威廉姆森产生了一个他称之为最震撼、最惊人的想法，即双方都认为自己在为同一个事业而战。这些穿灰衣服的人是好家庭出身。他们奇怪地就像我们自己一样，只是普通人。非常哲学。而且，多米尼克，我很惊讶这竟然没有变成一个神话。我完全期待你会揭穿它。
Yeah, I don't like debunking. Not on Christmas Day. So there was a truce, but I suppose then the obvious question is, well, how does it come to an end? And also that question that you mentioned at the start of this first half, why didn't they just stop fighting? You know, why did they, when Boxing Day came, start shooting each other again? Why did the crumps return? And I suppose the biggest question of all, what about the football? Did they play that?
是的，我不喜欢揭穿。圣诞节那天不行。所以确实有休战，但我猜接下来的显而易见的问题是，嗯，它是如何结束的？还有你在上半场开始时提到的那个问题，为什么他们不直接停止战斗？你知道，为什么当节礼日到来时，他们又开始互相射击了？为什么炮火又回来了？我想最大的问题是，足球呢？他们踢了吗？
And if so, did the Germans win on penalties? We will find out after the break. So Christmas dawned, wrapped in mist to open itself and offer the day like a gift. for Harry, Hugo, Herman, Henry Heinz. With whistles, waves, cheers, shouts, laughs. Frue, Vainachton, Tommy, Merry Christmas, Fritz. A young Berliner, brandishing schnapps, was the first from his ditch to climb.
如果是这样，德国人点球赢了吗？休息后我们会找到答案。圣诞节在薄雾中破晓，它展现自己，像礼物一样奉献出这一天。为了哈里、雨果、赫尔曼、亨利·海因茨。伴随着哨声、挥手、欢呼、呐喊、笑声。“圣诞快乐，汤米”，“圣诞快乐，弗里茨”。一个挥舞着杜松子酒的年轻柏林人是第一个从战壕里爬出来的人。
A Shropshire lad ran at him, like a rhyme. Then it was up and over every man to shake the hand of a foe as a friend or slap his back like a brother would, exchanging gifts of biscuits, tea, mackonicke's stew, tickler's jam, for cognac, sausages, cigars, beer, sauerkraut, or chase six hairs who jumped from a cabbage patch, or find a ball, and make of a battleground, a football pitch.
一个什罗普郡的小伙子像押韵诗一样向他跑去。然后每个人都起身越过战壕，像朋友一样握住敌人的手，或者像兄弟一样拍拍他的背，交换饼干、茶、麦康尼克炖肉、蒂克勒果酱，换取干邑、香肠、雪茄、啤酒、酸菜，或者追逐从卷心菜地里跳出来的六只野兔，或者找个球，把战场变成足球场。
So that was the Christmas truce by William McGonagall. Oh, no, it wasn't. It was by Carol Ann Duffy, and it was published in 2011, and it was also released as an illustrated children's book. And Dominant, you've written, perfectly captures the slightly maudlin sentimentality that now surrounds this story.
所以那是威廉·麦格纳戈尔写的《圣诞休战》。哦，不，不是。那是卡罗尔·安·达菲写的，出版于2011年，还被发行成了一本插图童书。多米尼克，你写道，它完美地捕捉到了现在围绕这个故事的那种略带伤感的感伤情绪。
Oh, no. I mean, there is a, there's a kind of Paddington-tinged quality of sentimentality about this whole story, I think. Yeah, there is. But I guess we'll maybe come on to that in a few minutes, but just for now, the idea that the soldiers made of a battleground, a football pitch. Yeah. Is this true? This is probably the most famous thing, isn't it, that people know about it? So this is the thing that has really gathered momentum in the last 20 years or so.
哦，不。我的意思是，整个故事有一种帕丁顿熊式的感伤色彩，我想。是的，确实有。但我猜我们几分钟后可能会谈到这一点，但就目前而言，士兵们把战场变成了足球场这个想法。是的。这是真的吗？这可能是人们所知道的关于它最著名的事情，不是吗？所以这就是在过去20年左右真正积聚了势头的事情。
So we mentioned the Sainsbury's advert. one of the most discussed adverts of the 21st century in Britain. If you Google it, there's loads of commentary about it. It's currently got 26 million views on YouTube. And I think if you ask people now, especially children, what happened at the Christmas truce, they will say they played football. Now, this has become one of the most bizarrely, one of the most hotly debated kind of questions of the whole First World War, particularly online. Yeah, because I've read so many different opposing opinions on this. Yes, mad. And especially on social media, on Twitter or something. People will be ripping into each other about this question. But what's interesting,
所以我们提到了塞恩斯伯里的广告。这是英国21世纪讨论最多的广告之一。如果你谷歌一下，会有大量的评论。它目前在YouTube上有2600万次观看。我想如果你现在问人们，特别是孩子们，圣诞休战时发生了什么，他们会说他们踢了足球。现在，这已经成为整个第一次世界大战中最离奇、最激烈争论的问题之一，特别是在网上。是的，因为我读过很多关于这个问题的不同对立观点。是的，太疯狂了。特别是在社交媒体上，在推特之类的平台上。人们会因为这个问题而互相攻击。但有趣的是，
it's quite like the Angels of Mons that we did a bonus on, you know, the story that kind of blows up. And that turns out to be completely rubbish. But this one seems to have a substratum of truth. A tiny substratum of truth, exactly. So let's get into the most, so the most celebrated football story of all. So the one you will see, if you Google it, or if you look in a random newspaper report, is that there was definitely a match, at least one match. It was played between the 133rd Royal Saxon Regiment, Germans, and a team of Scottish soldiers. They paid on frozen ground, caps for goalposts, and the result... Hmm. Mm-hmm.
这很像我们做过一期特别节目的“蒙斯天使”，你知道，那种突然爆发的故事。结果发现完全是胡扯。但这个故事似乎有一个真相的底层。一个微小的真相底层，没错。所以让我们进入最著名的足球故事。所以如果你谷歌一下，或者看一份随机的报纸报道，你会看到的就是肯定有一场比赛，至少有一场。它是在第133皇家萨克森团（德国人）和一队苏格兰士兵之间进行的。他们在冻土上比赛，用帽子当球门柱，结果是……嗯。嗯。
The result, Tom, are you really scoffing? No, I'm not. I was, you know, caps for goalpost. Yeah? Caps for goalpost, I know. And the result was 3-2 to the Germans. So here's the most famous account that's often quoted from the British side. We provided the football and we set up stretch. as goalposts, stretches not caps. And the Reverend Jolly, our Padre, acted as ref. They beat
结果，汤姆，你真的在嘲笑吗？不，我没有。我只是，你知道，用帽子当球门柱。是吗？用帽子当球门柱，我知道。结果是德国人3比2获胜。所以这是英方经常引用的最著名的说法。我们提供了足球，我们用担架搭起了球门柱，是担架，不是帽子。我们的随军牧师乔利牧师担任裁判。他们以
us three-two, but the Padre had showed a bit too much Christian charity. Their outside left shot the deciding goal, but he was miles offside and admitted it as soon as the whistle went. And we spectators were spread nearly too deep along the touchlines with loaded rifles slung on our shoulders. The Scots are the best at football in the world at this point, aren't they? They were their passing game and everything, whereas the Germans aren't really playing football. So I find it improbable that the Scots would lose three, two, to the Germans, actually. Well, you'd be right. You're right, Tom.
三比二击败了我们，但牧师表现出了太多的基督徒仁慈。他们的左边锋射进了决定性的一球，但他越位了好几码，哨声一响他就承认了。我们观众沿着边线站得太深，肩上还背着装满子弹的步枪。苏格兰人在这一点上是世界上踢足球最好的，不是吗？他们有传球配合什么的，而德国人并不是真的在踢足球。所以我认为苏格兰人以三比二输给德国人是不太可能的。嗯，你是对的。你是对的，汤姆。
Your historical instincts have served you well. Because this story is total fiction. It's actually from a short story by Robert Graves. Now, Robert Graves did serve on the Western Front. He wrote a very, probably the most famous First World War memoir, goodbye to all that. But this is fiction. Yeah, but this is fiction because he didn't actually arrive until 1915. So this is very, again, like the Angels of Modern.
你的历史直觉很好。因为这个故事完全是虚构的。它实际上来自罗伯特·格雷夫斯的一篇短篇小说。现在，罗伯特·格雷夫斯确实在西线服役过。他写了一本可能是最著名的第一次世界大战回忆录《再见，一切》。但这只是小说。是的，但这只是小说，因为他直到1915年才真正到达那里。所以这非常像“蒙斯天使”。
which begins with a piece of fiction that got recycled and is now taken as an authentic report. Yeah, that's right. Now, there are accounts that are not fiction. So here is one from a soldier who was in that regiment, the 133rd of the Saxons. Lieutenant Johannes Nieman, he gave an interview about it in the 1960s. He describes in this interview, you know, standard stuff. We met in no man's land. We exchanged cigarettes and shnaps and chocolate.
它以一段被循环利用并现在被视为真实报道的虚构片段开始。是的，没错。现在，有一些不是虚构的记录。所以这里有一位来自那个团（第133萨克森团）的士兵的记录。约翰内斯·尼曼中尉，他在20世纪60年代接受了关于此事的采访。他在采访中描述了，你知道，标准的东西。我们在无人区见面。我们交换了香烟、杜松子酒和巧克力。
And then he says, a Scottish soldier appeared with a football, which seemed to come from nowhere. and a real football match got underway. The Scots marked their goldmouth with their strange caps, and we did the same with ours. He said we played for about an hour, and then our commanding officer found out that we were playing, and he said, come on, stop all this. And we drifted back to our trenches,
然后他说，一个苏格兰士兵带着一个足球出现了，它似乎是从天而降的。一场真正的足球比赛开始了。苏格兰人用他们奇怪的帽子标记了球门，我们也用我们的帽子做了同样的事。他说我们踢了大约一个小时，然后我们的指挥官发现我们在踢球，他说，得了吧，停止这一切。然后我们回到了我们的战壕，
and the fraternization ended. Now, this is one of many stories of people playing football. But it's from the 1960s. This is from the 1960s, from afterwards. So we'll come back to whether or not it is this particular story is true or not. There are tons of stories like this, and a lot of real kind of proper First World War military historians, this drives them absolutely bonkers. So there's a bloke who does a lot of sort of consultancy work for TV and documentaries
联欢结束了。现在，这是许多关于人们踢足球的故事之一。但这是来自20世纪60年代。这是来自20世纪60年代，是事后才有的。所以我们会回到这个特定的故事是否真实的问题上。有成吨这样的故事，很多真正专业的第一次世界大战军事历史学家，这让他们绝对抓狂。所以有一个家伙为电视和纪录片做很多咨询工作，
and stuff called Taff Gillingham. And if you look at his online presence, you will see that for the last 15 years, he has been trapped and unable to escape from a Christmas truce football-related rabbit hole. So he doesn't believe it? He doesn't believe it. He's investigated all these stories. I mean, that thing about that the German soldier says about the football, which seemed to come from nowhere, I mean, it's a bit like the pig, isn't it? But I think the pig is true.
之类的，叫塔夫·吉林汉姆。如果你看看他的在线状态，你会发现过去15年来，他一直被困在圣诞休战足球相关的兔子洞里，无法逃脱。所以他不相信？他不相信。他调查了所有这些故事。我的意思是，关于德国士兵说的那个足球，似乎是从天而降的，我的意思是，这有点像那头猪，不是吗？但我认为那头猪是真的。
I think the pig is true. But that's what I'm wondering. I mean, if there's a pig, why can't they be a football? Well, let's see what this bloke, Taff Gillingham says. He says, most of these stories are the product of frauds and fantasists after the war. Most accounts of football in letters and diaries at the time say they wanted to play, but they didn't have a ball. or they did have a ball but their commanding officer wouldn't let them
我认为那头猪是真的。但这就是我所怀疑的。我的意思是，如果有一头猪，为什么不能有一个足球？嗯，让我们看看这个家伙，塔夫·吉林汉姆怎么说。他说，大多数这些故事是战后骗子和幻想家的产物。当时信件和日记中大多数关于足球的记录都说他们想踢，但他们没有球，或者他们确实有球，但他们的指挥官不让他们踢，
or they said we'll play in a few days but when the few days came around they were already fighting again so the football never happened however Tom this is the twist he thinks there are two stories that do stand up so not total debunking today so one of them is that story by
或者他们说我们过几天再踢，但当那几天到来时，他们已经在战斗了，所以足球赛从未发生过。然而，汤姆，这就是转折点，他认为有两个故事是站得住脚的。所以今天不是完全揭穿。其中一个是关于
Johannes Neiman because there's another account by a German soldier in the same regiment who wrote to his mother and said we played British soldiers So two men in the same regiment. And these British soldiers were probably Scots, the second Argyll and Sutherland Highlanders. They were stationed at a place called Fralingen, which was right on the border between France and Belgium.
约翰内斯·尼曼的故事，因为同一个团的另一名德国士兵写信给他的母亲说我们和英国士兵踢了球。所以同一个团里的两个人。而这些英国士兵可能是苏格兰人，第二阿盖尔和萨瑟兰高地团。他们驻扎在一个叫弗拉林根的地方，就在法国和比利时的边界上。
And then there's a second story that stands up. There was a group of the Norfolk and Cheshire regiments at a place called Vulvigem in Belgium. And there are, again, two different sources, a sergeant and a corporal who mentioned playing football. We had a rare old jollification, which included. did football in which the Germans took part. So actually, when you see the Sainsbury's advert, the bloke's in that advert are from these regiments, because this bloke, Taff Gillingham, was the military consultant. He said, they have to wear the right caps.
然后是第二个站得住脚的故事。在比利时一个叫沃尔维根的地方，有一群诺福克和柴郡团的士兵。而且，同样有两个不同的来源，一名中士和一名下士提到了踢足球。我们进行了一次难得的狂欢，其中包括足球，德国人也参加了。所以实际上，当你看到塞恩斯伯里的广告时，广告里的家伙就是来自这些团的，因为这个家伙，塔夫·吉林汉姆，是军事顾问。他说，他们必须戴正确的帽子。
You know what, military consultants. I do. So he made a massive fuss about all this. They had the correct putties and whatnot. And so, you know, he was very happy. However, a lot of First World War historians are really bitter. as they see it, the football industry, meaning UEFA, and I'm sorry to say, the English Football Association, have hijacked the Christmas truce for their own self-interested PR reasons. Dominic, could I, and this is not something that you often hear on podcasts, stick up for FIFA at this point?
你知道吗，军事顾问。我知道。所以他对此大惊小怪。他们有正确的绑腿之类的。所以，你知道，他非常高兴。然而，许多第一次世界大战的历史学家真的很痛苦。正如他们所看到的，足球产业，意味着欧足联，我很抱歉地说，英格兰足球协会，为了他们自己利益相关的公关原因劫持了圣诞休战。多米尼克，我能，而且这不是你在播客中经常听到的，在这一点上为国际足联辩护吗？
What? That's mad. I know it's Christmas, but that's absolutely disgraceful. The worst organisation of the world, Tom. in um it was what it was jonathan wilson and rob draper in their podcast on this they discuss the FIFA museum where i think rob had been uh and he reported that FIFA are very skeptical about it and the the salient reason that they think it's obviously nonsense is because the pitch would have been too churned up for them to play which i think is a really an excellent reason but the pitch was frozen yeah but you can't play on you know i mean there'd be i'll tell you
什么？那太疯狂了。我知道是圣诞节，但这绝对是可耻的。世界上最糟糕的组织，汤姆。在乔纳森·威尔逊和罗布·德雷珀关于这个问题的播客中，他们讨论了国际足联博物馆，我想罗布去过那里，他报道说国际足联对此非常怀疑，他们认为这显然是胡说八道的根本原因是球场会被踩得太烂而无法踢球，我认为这是一个非常好的理由，但球场是冻住的。是的，但你不能在上面踢，你知道，我的意思是会有，我会告诉你
you why FIFA don't like it, because it's UEFA who are promoting it. So it's an internal football rivalry between two different organisations. So this has actually driven historians mad with rage. And lots of First World War historians are really keen to downplay the football. And they point out that actually a lot of soldiers had no interest in playing football. They just wanted to hobnob and smoke cigarettes and sort of bury the dead and all that kind of thing. Do you think this is because First World War historians were the kind of boy who never played football at school. Possibly. They hated sport. Every now and again, they catch a glimpse of Prince William at a memorial in his capacity is head of the FA. Your friend, Prince William, a fellow
为什么国际足联不喜欢它，因为是欧足联在推广它。所以这是两个不同组织之间的内部足球竞争。所以这实际上让历史学家愤怒得抓狂。许多第一次世界大战的历史学家非常热衷于淡化足球。他们指出，实际上许多士兵根本没有兴趣踢足球。他们只是想社交、抽烟、埋葬死者等等。你认为这是因为第一次世界大战的历史学家是那种在学校里从不踢足球的男孩吗？有可能。他们讨厌运动。偶尔，他们会瞥见威廉王子在纪念活动中以足协主席的身份出现。你的朋友，威廉王子，一个阿斯顿维拉的支持者，汤姆，这让他们愤怒得抓狂。所以我们应该停止谈论足球，因为任何听这个节目且热爱第一次世界大战的人，蒸汽会从他们耳朵里冒出来。让我们回到亨利·威廉姆森，我们以他开启了这一集。但我能说一下吗，关于足球我们决定了什么，有一两场？一两场无精打采的比赛，仅此而已。但这并不是真正的比赛。他们只是在踢着玩。不，他们只是在踢球。当它像说，哦，他们越位了，他们在踢左翼之类的。他们甚至没有踢正规的位置。
Aston Villa supporter, Tom, and it drives them mad with rage. So we should stop talking about football because anyone listening to this who loves the First World War, we steam will be coming out there is. Let's go back to Henry Williamson, with whom we opened the episode. But can I just say, what have we decided about the football, that there were one or two? One or two desultry games, that's it. But it wasn't really a match. They were just kicking it about. No, they're just kicking a ball around. When it's like saying, oh, they're offside, they're playing left wing and stuff. They're not even playing proper positions.
他们没有裁判，这完全是一团糟。总之，亨利·威廉姆森，它是怎么结束的？他在20年后为《每日快报》写的一篇非常抒情的文章中描述了它是如何结束的。他说，你知道，第二天很安静。我们在互相挥手，我认为这可能是真的。他们是在向他们的伙伴，他们来自萨克森的新伙伴之类的挥手。然后在圣诞节后的第三天，一个德国人送来了一个信息。午夜，我们的参谋军官来访，我们必须发射我们的自动手枪，
They don't have a referee, it's all the shambles. Anyway, Henry Williamson, how does it end? He describes how it ended in an article they wrote, a very lyrical article for the Daily Express 20 years later. And he says, you know, the next day was quiet. We were waving to each other, which I think is probably true. They were waving to each other kind of to their mates, their new mates from Saxony or whatever. And then on the third day, after Christmas, a German sent across a message. At midnight, our staff officer's visit, and we must fire our automatic pistolan,
但我们会打高一点。尽管如此，请保持隐蔽。然后两天后，英国总部下达了命令。如果你再与敌人联欢，你将被送上军事法庭，如果被判有罪，你将面临死刑。然后在那之后，亨利·威廉姆森说，照明弹在夜间飞过无人区，子弹从树木中切下碎片，有时是人类的血肉和骨头。现在，这一切背后是一个非常迷人的个人故事，
but we will fire high. Nevertheless, please keep undercover. Then two days after that, there is an order from British headquarters. If you fraternize with the enemy anymore, you will be court-martialed, and if you're found guilty, you'll suffer the death penalty. And then after that, says Henry Williamson, the very light soared over no man's land at night, and bullets cut showers of splinters from the trees and sometimes human flesh and bone. Now, behind all this is a really fascinating personal story,
一些听众可能已经熟悉了。所以亨利·威廉姆森，正如我们提到的，当时19岁。他服完了战争剩下的时间。他成为了一名机枪手。他中了毒气，直到1919年才离开军队。他可能是写过圣诞休战最著名的人，部分原因是他深受其影响。他一生中又写了三四次关于它的文章，有不同的记录。
which some listeners may already be familiar with. So Henry Williamson, as we mentioned, was 19 at the time. He served out the rest of the war. He became a machine gunner. He was gassed, and he didn't leave the army till 1919. And he's probably the most famous person to have written about the Christmas truce, in part because he was profoundly. affected by it. He wrote about it about three or four more times in his life, different accounts.
它完全定义了他的一生。他变得完全沉迷于这种英国和德国士兵之间亲缘关系的想法。所以到了20世纪30年代，那时他已经成为了一名畅销作家，这些儿童自然经典作品的作者，他也成为了一名和平主义者。他开始相信另一位声称代表所有士兵的战壕老兵也是像他一样的和平主义者。那个士兵是谁？那个人的名字是什么，多米尼克？那个人的名字。哦，但是爱因斯坦？不。是阿道夫·希特勒。哦，不。是的。亨利·威廉姆森在那里经历了一个令人震惊的时刻。所以他成了希特勒的超级粉丝。他说希特勒是和平主义者。希特勒热爱我们两国之间的亲缘关系。然后在1930年，当战争爆发时，
It completely defined his life. He became completely obsessed by this idea of the kinship between British and German soldiers. So by the 1930s, by which time he'd become a best-selling writer, the writer of these nature classics for children, he had also become a pacifist. And he came to believe that another trench veteran who claimed to speak for all. soldiers was also a pacifist like him. And who was this soldier? What was the name of that man, Dominic? The name of that man. Oh, but Einstein? No. It was Adolf Hitler. Oh, no. Yeah. Henry Williamson's had a shocking moment there. So he became a huge fan of Hitler. He said Hitler's a pacifist. Hitler loves the kinship between our two nations. And then in 1930, when war broke out,
亨利·威廉姆森，到这个时候，基本上已经是一个法西斯主义者了。他说，我将立即飞往德国。他不得不被朋友劝阻之类的。他说，我想飞往德国去见希特勒。让我们像战壕老兵一样以男人的方式解决这个问题。所以就像鲁道夫·赫斯的倒影。就像鲁道夫·赫斯的倒影。如果我能以一个在1914年那个遥远的圣诞节联欢过的普通士兵的身份见到他，亨利·威廉姆森在这里有误解。他认为希特勒参加了圣诞休战，但他没有。我难道不能给他那种他从英格兰，他所钦佩的国家，如此渴望的友谊吗？你知道，威廉姆森这种可怕的判断错误使他成为了一个被放逐者，真的，
Henry Williamson, by this point, was basically a fascist. And he said, I shall fly immediately. to Germany. He had to be dissuaded by friends or whatever. He said, I want to fly to Germany to meet Hitler. And let's settle this as man to man as trench veterans. So like Rudolf Hess in reverse. Like Rudolph Hess in reverse. If I could see him as a common soldier who had fraternized on that faraway Christmas day of 1914, Henry Williamson is under misapprehension here. He thinks that Hitler was at the Christmas truce, which he wasn't. Might I not be able to give him the amity he's so desired from England, the country he admired. You know, this terrible error of judgment from Williamson made him an outcast, really,
一个政治上的被放逐者。所以，你知道，如果你现在谷歌他，上面写着，《塔卡水獭》的作者，每个人都喜欢这本书，也是一个法西斯主义者，这很不幸。事实上，汤姆，这是一个客观的教训，我总是告诉西奥，即十字军式的左翼理想主义和和平主义可以把你带到一些非常黑暗的地方。所以这就是今天这一集的重要教训。如果这不是一个适时的圣诞信息，我不知道什么才是。完全正确。
a political outlast. So, you know, if you Google him now, it says, author of Tarka the Otter, everybody loves this book, also a bit of a fascist, which is unfortunate. And actually, Tom, it's an object lesson, something I always tell Theo, which is crusading left-wing idealism and pacifism can lead you into some very dark places. So that's the important lesson of today's episode. If that's not an opportune Christmas message, I don't know what is. Exactly.
那么亨利·威廉姆森的战友们是怎么想的呢？嗯，事实上，首先，我们知道许多英国军官对圣诞休战感到非常惊恐。他们认为，战争注定会再次开始，德国人会再次进攻，如果我们的士兵在想到共享罐头果酱、烤猪和足球比赛时擦掉男人的眼泪，他们将很难战斗和保卫自己。我想那是，他们没错。我的意思是，有一位叫迈克·达什的历史学家，他引用了一位年轻军官，东兰开夏团的理查兹中尉的话。
So what did Henry Williamson's fellow soldiers think about it? Well, actually, first of all, we know that a lot of British officers were seriously alarmed by the Christmas truce. They thought the officers, the war was bound to start again, the Germans will attack again, and our soldiers will struggle to fight and to defend themselves if they're sort of wiping away manly tears at the thought of shared tins of jam and roasted. pigs and football matches and stuff. I think that's, they're not wrong. I mean, there's a historian called Mike Dash, who quotes the young officer, Lieutenant Richards of the East Lancashire Regiment.
这个家伙，理查兹中尉，对圣诞休战感到非常震惊，当射击再次开始时，他很高兴。他说，你知道，老式的狙击，他说，很高兴看到一些好的老式狙击。因为他真的很担心。他想，你知道，当德国人进攻时，我的手下会被杀，因为他们只会试图握手，而德国人会用刺刀刺他们之类的。所以这就是为什么，你知道，双方的总部都下达了命令，不再联欢
This boat, Lieutenant Richards, was absolutely appalled by the Christmas truce, and he was delighted when this firing started again. He said, you know, good old-fashioned sniping, he said, great to see some good old-fashioned sniping. Because he was really worried. He thought, you know, my men will be killed when the Germans attack, because they'll just be trying to shake hands and the Germans will ban at them or something. So this is why, you know, the headquarters on both sides issue orders, no more fraternization
在圣诞节和新年之间。像史密斯·多里安将军这样的人，他在节礼日去过前线，他说，得了吧，这有点松懈。你知道，我们不能做所有这些，因为战争会再次开始，而且，你知道，我们需要处于一种战斗状态。所以那是军官们。普通汤米们呢？现在，我们从普通汤米那里得到的记录，正如你已经提到的，
in the period between Christmas and New Year. People like General Smith Dorian, he'd been to the front lines on Boxing Day, and he said, come on, this is a bit slack. You know, we can't be doing all this because the war will start again, and, you know, we need to be in kind of fighting mood. So that's the officers. What's about the ordinary tommies? Now, most of the accounts that we have from Ordinary Tom is come, as you've already mentioned,
来自多年以后，从一个普遍认为战争是悲剧性浪费的时刻。但在当时，信件和日记显示，大多数人仍然非常真诚地相信他们的事业，并想在最后战斗。嗯，多米尼克，即使是后来成为和平主义者的亨利·威廉姆森，我的意思是，你说他成为了一名机枪手，他在1919年还在向人们开火，我认为这显示了对战争过度的热情。是的，是的，完全正确，完全正确。所以另一位英国士兵后来写道，那天双方都没有一丝仇恨，然而在我们这边，战争的意志和击败他们的意志一刻也没有放松。
from years afterwards, from a point at which it was common to see the war as a tragic waste. But at the time, the letters and dires show that most men still very sincerely believed in their cause and wanted to fight at the end. Well, Dominant, even Henry Williamson, who goes on to become a pacifist, I mean, you said he becomes a machine gunner and he's still having a cracker people in 1919, which I think shows excess enthusiasm for the war. Yeah, yeah, exactly, exactly. So another British soldier wrote later, there was not an atom of hate on either side that day, and yet on our side, not for a moment, was the will to war and the will to beat them relaxed.
但这是一种非常体育化的意识形态，不是吗？你知道，你握手，但随后你出去并努力比赛。嗯，这里有一个完美的体育信息给你。步枪旅的乔治·埃德。他写信给他的家人谈到休战，他说，我和一个会说流利英语的德国炮兵交了朋友。当我们分开时，他说，那个德国家伙对我说，今天我们和平。明天，你为你的国家而战。我为我的国家而战。祝你好运。
But that's very kind of sporting ideology, isn't it? You know, you shake hands, but then you go out and you play hard. Well, here's a perfect sporting message for you. George Ede of the Rifle Brigade. He wrote to his family about the truce, and he said, I made friends with a German artilleryman who spoke good English. And when we parted, he said, the German bloke said to me, Today we have peace. Tomorrow, you fight for your country. I fight for mine. Good luck.
现在这很可爱，但这并不向我暗示他们想停止战争。它暗示正如你所说，这就像橄榄球比赛中的运动员，半场休息时，你知道，微笑和握手，而我在下半场绝对会全力以赴。这里实际上有一些会让人们对普通士兵感到惊讶的事情。有相当多的普通士兵根本不赞成休战，并拒绝遵守它。所以第二掷弹兵卫队，他们在圣诞节前遭受了惨重的损失。当德国人从他们的战壕里冒出来并大喊圣诞快乐时，掷弹兵卫队射杀了他们。那会是一个精彩的塞恩斯伯里广告。有德国人越过无人区而
Now that's lovely, but it doesn't suggest to me that they want the war to stop. It suggests that exact as you say, it's like sportsmen in a rugby match, a half-time, you know, smiling and shaking hands, and I'm going to absolutely go for you in the second half. And here is something actually that will surprise people about ordinary soldiers. There were quite a lot of ordinary soldiers who did not approve of the truth at all and refused to honor it. So the second grenadier guards, they had suffered heavy losses before Christmas. When the Germans popped up from their trench and shouted Merry Christmas, the Grenadier guards shot them. That would make a brilliant same series advert. There are accounts of Germans coming across no man's land and the
英国人只是射杀他们的记录。我的意思是，这并非闻所未闻。有英国部队在圣诞节后互相争斗的记录，那些遵守了休战的人和那些没有遵守的人。因为那些没有遵守休战的家伙对其他人说，你们是叛徒，你们软弱，所有这些事情。你们在想什么？你知道，我的伙伴死在，你知道，12月12日左右。而你们在这里和杀死他们的人握手？事实上，非常引人注目的是，记住这正如我们所说，它在某种程度上是比利时和法国的固定装置
British just shooting them. I mean, this is not unheard of. There are accounts of British units after Christmas, fighting among themselves, those who have honored the truce and those who have not. Because the guys who have not honored the truce say to the others, you are traitors, you are weak, all of this kind of thing. What were you thinking of? You know, my mate died on, you know, the 12th of December or something. And here are you shaking hands with the people who killed them? And actually, very strikingly, remember this is happening, as we said, it's in a way fixture
西蒙·琼斯举了皇家威尔士燧发枪团的一个单位的例子，他们圣诞节那天和德国人一起喝酒，他们在节礼日被撤出前线，当他们行军回来时，法国妇女在街上向他们吐口水，说你们怎么敢和
in Belgium and France. Simon Jones gives the example of a Royal Welch Fusiliers unit They'd spent Christmas Day drinking with the Germans They were withdrawn from the line on Boxing Day And as they marched back French women lined the streets to spit at them Saying how dare you have a great laugh
入侵我们领土并破坏我们城镇的人一起大笑。我们知道吗？德国和法国士兵之间有任何联欢吗？不，真的没有。我的意思是，这并不奇怪。法国人是在为他们的祖国而战，他们损失的人数比英国人多得多。
With the people who have invaded our territory And to spoil our towns Do we know? Was there any fraternisation Between German and French soldiers? No, not at all really I mean, not surprising. The French are fighting for their native land And they've lost far more men than the British have.
嗯，事实上，我们稍后会在战争中谈到一个法国和德国之间有休战的例子。但那是跳得有点远了。所以这一切是如何结束的？战斗在节礼日以一种非常敷衍的方式重新开始。实际上并不是因为士兵们不情愿。是因为天气又变坏了，因为雪变成了雨夹雪。战壕里有洪水。所以这意味着直到新年之前没有太多的战斗。
Well, actually, we'll come to an example later in the war where there is a truth between France and Germany. But that's jumping ahead a little bit. So how does it all end? The fighting restarts on Boxing Day in a very half-hearted fashion. It's actually not because the men are reluctant. It's because the weather turns bad again because the snow turns to sleet. There's flooding in the trenches. So that means there's not that much fighting until New Year.
然后在新年，天气好转，战斗可以正式开始了。现在，到这个时候，休战的消息已经传遍了世界。它是由《纽约时报》打破的，我认为很有意义，一份来自中立国家的报纸，在12月31日。然后你得到了一系列报道，主要是在英国，实际上。有趣的是，报道确实主要是在英国。所以德国或法国真的没有任何报道？真的没有。德国有一些报道，法国真的完全没有。我想这是因为在英国，风险不像在法国和德国那样高。我的意思是，它们相当高。我的意思是，别误会我，它们仍然很高，但它不像对
And then in the New Year, the weather improves and the fighting can begin. in earnest. Now, by this point, news of the truce has gone around the world. It was broken by the New York Times, tellingly, I think, a paper from a neutral country on the 31st of December. And then you get a series of reports, mainly in Britain, actually. It's interesting that the reports really are predominantly in Britain. So there aren't any in Germany, really, or France? Not really. There are some reports in Germany, none at all really in France. I think it's because in Britain, the stakes are not quite as high as they are. I mean, they're pretty high. I mean, don't get me wrong, they're still high, but it's not quite as existential as it is
法国人和德国人那样存在主义。事实上，有趣的是，《曼彻斯特卫报》当时是自由派舆论的声音，说，哦，事实上，大多数报纸说，哦，他们在圣诞节休战不是很可爱吗？相当令人惊讶的是，即使在宣传中，人们也赞扬它。《曼彻斯特卫报》，人类灵魂在面对共同而绝望的困境时被吸引在一起的简单而未经审视的冲动。然后《卫报》有这一行社论。它说，外星人会对我们能在圣诞节停止然后又重新开始这一事实作何感想？
for the French and the Germans. And actually, the interesting thing, so the Manchester Guardian is then, was the voice of liberal opinion says, oh, in fact, most papers say, oh, isn't it lovely they had a truce on Christmas Day? Quite surprising that even in the mid of propaganda, people, they applaud it. Manchester Guardian, the simple and unexamined impulse of human souls drawn together in the face of a common and desperate plight. And then the Guardian has this. line in the editorial. It says, what would an alien from outer space make of the fact that we could stop on Christmas day and then start again?
为什么我们要开始杀戮？《卫报》说，我们可能会非常有理由地回答说，还有很多事情要做。比利时必须从强加给她的可怕枷锁中解放出来，德国必须被教导文化不能通过剑来传播。这就是答案。正如他们所见，风险太大了，即使在自由派舆论中，人们也想重新开始战争。
Why would we start the killing? And the Guardian says, we might reply with great reason that there was very much to be done yet. The Belgium must be freed from the hideous yoke that has been thrust upon her, that Germany must be taught that culture cannot be carried by the sword. There's the answer. There is so much at stake as they see it, and even in liberal opinion, that people want to restart the war.
他们不是不情愿地这样做。他们这样做是因为他们相信它。你看，这就是我们圣诞节特别节目中经典的桑布鲁克转折。啊，谢谢。所以到一月中旬，战争正式重新开始。我们将在明年夏天，2026年夏天，谈论1915年的第一次世界大战的故事。值得一提的是，这不是战争中最后一次休战。
They're not doing it reluctantly. They're doing it because they believe in it. You see, this is the classic Sanbrook Twist on our Christmas Day special. Ah, thanks. So by mid-January, the war is back on an earnest. We'll be coming to the story of the First World War in 1915 next summer, in the summer of 2026. Worth saying this isn't the last truce of the war.
在加里波利有一次官方休战，在整个第一次世界大战中是独一无二的，在1915年5月，为了让双方，对，因为那不会是圣诞休战，是吗？不，澳大利亚人和土耳其人埋葬他们的死者。1915年圣诞节有更多小规模的休战，实际上，西奥听到这个会很震惊，1915年圣诞节在孚日山脉法国和德国军队之间有一次休战，那实际上激励了一名德国士兵理查德·谢尔曼在战后建立了第一个青年旅舍协会，因为他深受启发。他不是谢尔曼坦克里的那个谢尔曼吧？不，不，不，不，不。我的意思是，那会是一个相当不错的双重节目，不是吗？
There was an official truce at Gallipoli, uniquely in the whole course of the First World War in May 1915 to enable both sides Right, because that wouldn't have been a Christmas truce, would it? No, Australians and Turks to bury their dead. There were more small-scale trucees at Christmas 1915 And actually, Theo will be shocked to hear this, there was a truce between French and German troops in the Vosges,
那会是一个转折。但到了1916年、1917年，就没有休战了。为什么？因为索姆河和凡尔登战役，你知道，大规模的流血意味着这几乎是不可能的。而且，你不能在索姆河战场上踢足球。我的意思是，那会是一团糟。嗯，人们尝试过。
Christmas 1915, and that actually inspired a German soldier, Richard Sherman, to set up the first youth hostess on association after the war because he was so inspired. He wasn't Sherman as in the tanks as well. No, no, no, no, no. I mean, that would be quite a double bill, wouldn't it?
一个家伙在索姆河第一天开始时，有一个非常著名的故事，关于一个人踢球并追赶，然后他立即被射杀了。是的，但这不是比赛。我的意思是，你可以踢球，但你不能运球。他在球上写着伟大的欧洲杯决赛，然后他被射杀了。哦，天哪。是的，太可怕了。那么圣诞休战的记忆发生了什么？
That would be a twist. But by 1916, 1917, there are no truces. Why? Because the battles of the Somme and Verdum, you know, the massive bloodletting means it's pretty much impossible. And also, you couldn't play football on the battlefield of the Somme. I mean, that would be total mess. Well, people tried to.
这里有一件有趣的事。每个人都忘记了它。战后它完全被盟军的喜悦和德国的，你知道，痛苦和受害者心态之类的所掩盖。事实上，我们所知道的圣诞休战，真的，是20世纪60年代的产物。具体来说，是戏剧《噢，多么可爱的战争》，
A bloke started when the first day of the Somme, there's a very famous story about a man kicking a ball and chasing off and he was shot immediately. Yeah, but it's not a match. I mean, you can kick a ball, but you can't dribble. He wrote on the ball the great European Cup tie final, and then he was shot dead. Oh, God. Yeah, terrible. So what happened to the memory of the Christmas truce?
由琼·利特尔伍德和她的戏剧工作室制作。在英国。所以这是只有在英国发生的事情。它没有在德国发生，比如说。完全正确。而戏剧工作室是那种大规模的，
Here's an interesting thing. Everybody forgot about it. It was completely eclipsed after the war by allied joy and German, you know, bitterness and victimhood and whatnot. And actually, the Christmas truce, as we know it, to do, is really a product of the 1960s. And specifically, the play, Oh, What a Lovely War,
在20世纪60年代初有大规模的左派和和平主义者之类的。而他们制作的《噢，多么可爱的战争》，戏剧，然后是60年代末的电影，是对第一次世界大战的控诉，特别是对将军们和政治体制以及战争背后的那种社会等级制度的控诉。
produced by Joan Littlewood and her theatre workshop. In Britain. And so this is something that is only happening in Britain. It's not happening in Germany, say. Exactly. And the theatre workshop was the sort of massive,
所以电影中的那个序列，在《平安夜》的配乐下，这是一个非常感人和令人难忘的序列。整个事情旨在强调西线的疯狂。这就是将休战变成人们所看到的战争恐怖和徒劳的象征的原因。
there were massive lefties and pacifists and whatnot in the early 1960s. And what they produced, Oh, What a Lovely War, the play and then the film at the end of the 60s, was an indictment of the First World War and particularly of the generals and the political establishment and the kind of social hierarchy that lay behind the war.
所以我开头提到了。关于这个有一些优秀的书籍。1984年马尔科姆·布朗和雪莉·西顿为70周年纪念写了一本书。然后2001年美国历史学家斯坦利·温特劳布又写了一本优秀的书。然后，你知道，我们听了卡罗尔·安·达菲的诗，但兴趣的真正高峰出现在2014年的百年纪念。为什么，我认为这实际上也是其背景的反映。你知道，伊拉克战争才过去几年。阿富汗战争仍在继续。
And so the sequence in the film, it's a very moving and memorable sequence to the soundtrack of Silent Night. The whole thing is designed to hammer home the madness of the Western Front. And this is what turns the truce into a kind of symbol for what people see is the horror and the futility of war.
这就是2014年，当时英国头条新闻中有很多关于退伍军人、女军人的身心健康的内容。人们戴着“帮助英雄”的腕带之类的。所以当第一次世界大战百年纪念到来时，我想人们非常关注战争的恐怖、怜悯和徒劳。而休战对人们来说是一个绝佳的象征。你认为足球在英国国民性格中是否也有一种深刻的感伤？我不知道它在其他国家是否像这样强烈，可能不是。但在英国，我的意思是，没有什么比老足球明星之类的记忆
So I mentioned at the beginning. There were some excellent books on this. There was a book for the 70th anniversary by Malcolm Brown and Shirley Seaton in 1984. And then another excellent book by an American historian Stanley Weintraub in 2001. And then, you know, we heard Caroline Duffy's poem, but the real peak of interest came in 2014 with the centenary. Why, I think this actually is also a reflection of its context. You know, the Iraq war is just a few years old. The war in Afghanistan is still going on.
更能让眼眶湿润，流下男儿泪了。是的。如果你去参加11月，11月初的阵亡将士纪念日比赛，你知道，这是一场英超比赛。你知道，这些天，关于，你知道，士兵们列队走出来，可能还有乐队和最后哨声之类的，有很多大惊小怪。我不记得几十年前发生过这种情况，但它现在已经制度化了。事实上，你知道，足球接管了2014年的纪念活动。所以你的朋友，威廉王子，
This is the point 2014 when there's lots of stuff in the British headlines about the physical and mental health of ex-servicemen, service women. People are wearing help for heroes, wristbands and whatnot. So that's sort of when the first World War centenary rolled around, I think the idea of the horror and the pity and the futility of war was very much on people's minds. And the truce was a brilliant symbol of that for people. Do you think also that there's just a deep vein of sentimentality about football? in the British national character. I don't know whether it's as virulent in other countries, probably not. But here, I mean, there's nothing like memories of an old football star or something
和当时的英格兰主教练罗伊·霍奇森揭幕了一个纪念碑，那是人们在里面握手，惊喜，惊喜，一个足球。罗伊·霍奇森，非常聪明。非常博学，汤姆。猫头鹰一样。是的。肯定他听了剩下的部分。我很想这么认为。用他的八种语言之一。完全正确。完全正确。这一切最大的讽刺是，战壕里的男人们会惊讶于休战竟然如此重要。因为正如我们所说，战争对他们来说还在继续，因为他们相信它，他们想打这场仗。我认为这对现在大多数人来说是一件非常难以接受的事情。所以我认为我们欺骗自己，认为1565天的战争是反常的，而休战更好地反映了人性。
to bring tears, a manly tear to the eye. Yeah. If you ever go to a Remembrance Day match, you know, in November, early November, it's a Premier League game. You know, these days, there's quite a big palaver about, you know, soldiers marching out and maybe a band and the last post and all of that. kind of thing. I don't remember that happening decades ago, but it's become kind of institutionalized now. And actually, you know, football took over the 2014 commemoration. So your friend, Prince William,
这就是多米尼克·桑布鲁克在圣诞节给国家和世界的信息。太棒了。大家圣诞快乐。是的。然而，汤姆，然而，这是圣诞节。我同意历史的教训是你的邻居正密谋杀死并吃掉你。但让我们以一个积极的圣诞音符结束。我想你应该带我们结束，带一些。
and the then-England manager, Roy Hodgson, unveiled a memorial, which was people shaking hands inside, surprise, surprise, a football. Roy Hodgson, very intelligent. Positively erudite, Tom. Owl-like. Yeah. Surely he listens to the rest of it. I'd love to think so. In one of his eight languages. Exactly. Exactly. The great irony of all this is the men in the trenches would be amazed that the truce looms so large. Because as we've said, the war went on for them because they believed in it and they wanted to fight it. And that is a really hard thing, I think, for most people now to accept. So I think we delude ourselves into thinking that the 1,565 days of war with the aberration and the truce better reflects human nature.
时任英格兰队主教练罗伊·霍奇森揭幕了一座纪念碑，碑上刻着人们在足球里握手的图案，真是令人惊讶。罗伊·霍奇森，非常聪明。汤姆，他简直博学多才。像猫头鹰一样睿智。是啊。他肯定听了剩下的部分。我真希望是这样。用他掌握的八种语言之一。没错。没错。这一切最大的讽刺在于，战壕里的士兵如果知道休战在后世被赋予如此重大的意义，一定会感到惊讶。因为正如我们所说，战争对他们来说仍在继续，因为他们信仰这场战争，并渴望战斗。我认为，这对现在大多数人来说是非常难以接受的。所以我认为我们是在自欺欺人，以为那1565天的战争是反常的，而休战反而更能反映人性。
And that is the Dominic Sambrook, message to the nation and the world on Christmas Day. Brilliant. Happy Christmas, everyone. Yeah. However, Tom, however, it is Christmas. I agree the lesson of history is that your neighbours are plotting to kill and eat you. But let's end on a positive Christmassy note. And I think you should take us out with some.
这就是多米尼克·桑布鲁克在圣诞节给全国乃至全世界带来的信息。太棒了。祝大家圣诞快乐。是啊。不过，汤姆，不管怎么说，今天是圣诞节。我同意历史的教训是你的邻居正密谋杀掉并吃掉你。但让我们以一个积极的圣诞基调结束吧。我觉得你应该带我们来点什么。
some lovely poetry from Caroline Duffey's festive poem to inspire the nation. Yeah, so some festive poetry and then perhaps right at the end, a little bit of music. And all that marvellous festive day and night, they came and went, the officers, the rank and file, their fallen comrades side by side beneath the makeshift crosses of midwinter graves, beneath the shivering, shy stars and the pinned moon and the yawn of history, the high, bright bullets, which each man later only aimed. at the sky. But Dominic, let's leave the last words on this Christmas morning to Sir Paul McCartney. I light a candle to our love. In love, our problems disappear. But all in all, we soon discover
来自卡罗琳·达菲（Caroline Duffey）节日诗作中一些优美的诗句，旨在激励全国人民。是的，先是一些节日诗歌，然后在最后，或许会有一点音乐。那所有美妙的节日昼夜，军官们、士兵们来来去去，他们倒下的战友并排躺在仲冬坟墓的简易十字架下，躺在颤抖、羞涩的星辰、被钉住的月亮和历史的哈欠之下，那些高处明亮的子弹，每个人后来都只是瞄准了天空。但是多米尼克，让我们在这个圣诞节的早晨，把最后的话留给保罗·麦卡特尼爵士。我为我们的爱点燃一支蜡烛。在爱中，我们的问题消失了。但总而言之，我们很快就会发现
that one and one is all we long to hear. Happy Christmas. Happy Christmas, everybody. Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一加一就是我们渴望听到的一切。圣诞快乐。祝大家圣诞快乐。谢谢。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。